obviously the mosque here is open anyone
wants to come a-knockin they can come in
and listen and learn and connect yes
what have you seen through your
experience our is the biggest
misconception now that people have about
it yes almost every Saturday I have
students from different universities
they found through the message they come
to the mosque here ask me questions most
of the questions are about what is the
holy war in Islam what is this concept
of jihad holy war and they get surprised
when I tell them that there is no holy
war in his name in Iraq and in fact
jihad does not mean holy war this word
holy war does not exist in the Islamic
terminology if you look at the book of
fake jurisprudence Islam is generous
with you will not find the holy war
because what is not holy in Islam so I
tell them do what is this jihad they say
this one I said well does not mean holy
war let me tell you what jihad means
jihad means to struggle to change
something bad to something good and
jihad is of three types there is jihad
struggling to change something bad to
good g'head with the shaitaan with the
satan
so the whispering of the Shaitaan we
change that we struggle we make jihad
all right to change that bad
whispering to good to something positive
in life to become productive in life
instead of just one I mean his bed evil
whispering there is jihad with the naps
jihad with oneself and that is to stop
one's evil and to change that evil
energy that we have into productive
energy into good energy that is also
jihad then the last we had which is the
jihad the fight against those who attack
the Muslim territory and also attack the
Muslims property and that is that has
you know rules and they'd have to have a
leader and the leader has to announce it
and the scholars have to agree on it is
a big concept it's not what they because
what they what usually we see we see
some individuals acting on their own and
using the name of Islam and Islam is far
from that like I said I gave them a
circle and I said the we have the text
are preserved the Quran and the Sunna
are preserved they not touched
unlike other religions when you go to
the original text they are not preserved
they were changed altered the Quran and
Sunnah they are not so God
God's Word are preserved in Islam so
therefore we have the circle of Islam
this is the circle some people are a
little bit outside of it some people are
very far from it
but the source is still clean you wanna
come back please come back and we want
you to come back we want you we don't
want you to go far to the extreme
that's what extreme means in in Islam
satoru meaning to go to the borders you
don't you're not in the circle go to the
borders and sometimes you go far from
the borders that's Tatar oh it's called
extremist ministry and that is what so
we the source is preserved that is the
difference in the Islam our sauce is
preserved all right so it's here you
wanna come back please come back but if
you are far from there you're not in the
circle so saying that you are
representing Islam is wrong